hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
is the 30th of July and you're tuned
into games one news first updates prices
and titles are being confirmed for the
Xbox one's launch in China the console
will hit shelves on sep tember 23 and
it's going to cost gamers roughly 600 US
dollars that casters for the system
copies of powerstar golf neverwinter
online and free access to xbox live gold
until March 2015 there's also a seven
hundred dollar day one edition which
will also include the Kinect a
commemorative controller kinect sports
rivals and 45 also some in-game credit
for powerstar golf which is pretty
indisputably the best inclusion the
system will also include Chinese
streaming service best TV this will mark
the first gaming console approved for
sale in China through the new Shanghai
free-trade zone microsoft has said the
regional release will have plenty of big
publisher support including 2 k EA and
Ubisoft and of course Microsoft have
said the big-name Chinese developers are
bringing new IP and fan favorite games
to the console as well next up I meant
it the other day when I said we don't
have numbers for who participated in the
destiny beta but now we do so here's the
mad stats according to Activision more
than 4.6 million people played the
recently-concluded beta publishing CEO
for Activision Eric Hirshberg said this
is the biggest beta of this console
generation by a wide margin and the
largest console beta ever for a new
video game IP to date hosting a beta at
this scale is an incredible feat so
we're thrilled to see the phenomenal
response but the beta is just a taste of
what's to come we're counting down the
days to our launch day September 9
nintendo released its financial results
for the last quarter and while mario
kart did its very best to pull the
company back up it didn't quite make it
out of the red Nintendo's year-on-year
revenue was down eight point four
percent as even though the company
posted 730 point five million dollars in
revenue they also posted an overall loss
of 97 million they sold five hundred and
ten thousand we use up from just a
hundred and sixty thousand sold
the same period last year 4.3 nine
million where you titles were shifted
2.8 two million of which were copies of
Mario Kart 8 which was sold in a single
month 820,000 3ds units were sold
alongside 8.5 seven million games both
figures of which are significantly down
from last year you may remember that EA
is launching their subscription program
for Xbox one exclusively but it turns
out that's just because Sony turned them
down the netflix style program that
gives gamers access to a collection of
EA games for five bucks a month what's
rejected by Sony for being bad battle
year the company said we evaluated the
EA Access subscription offering and
decided that it does not bring the kind
of value PlayStation customers have come
to expect Sony have said they favor
subscription plans like PlayStation Plus
over very specific services like EA
access let me know which big game you
reckon Nintendo could release this year
to pull themselves out of the red that
is it from me today as always do leave
me your thoughts and I'll see you
tomorrow